in doom I see a world brimming with
demons explosions and Hellfire and
playing it delivers the same cathartic
craze the original doom and doom to did
back in the early 90s but the new doom
is louder and faster than the old model
from the outset two things are made
immediately clear you were born to kill
demons and you'll do anything it takes
you will wrench countless jaws from
their joints and eviscerate the swollen
flesh of your enemies between bouts of
furious gunfire these powerful moments
carry what at its core is a simple game
the cadence of dooms campaign is
unwavering to the point of
predictability is you make multiple
round trips between Mars and the depths
of hell
it rarely takes an unexpected turn but
any bothersome feelings this gives you
our washed away the moment you enter
battle you're equipped with a range of
weapons that start simple and grow ever
more elaborate not all are created equal
but many are formidable and a near
constant stream of upgrades allows you
to tweak your favorites in order to give
them greater functionality and strength
more cause for attachment - and wonder
in the power of your fingertips
this power extends to glory coasts dooms
contextual dismemberment techniques that
can be triggered when you cause an enemy
to stack enemies occasionally drop
health items and ammo when felled by a
gun we are guaranteed an injection of
health when you Flay your opponents
using your bare hands and occasionally
with a body part of their own this
incentivizes you to rush in even when on
the brink offering hope at the end of a
potentially deadly tunnel similarly you
can also collect a chainsaw that can rip
demons in half as a one-hit kill which
causes ammo to satisfyingly spouts from
their corpses larger and more dangerous
demons appear over time and in greater
numbers as you weave and leap around
maze-like arenas to improve your Vantage
and search for much-needed supplies you
function like a magnet drawing enemies
toward you hurting enemies is par for
the course in doom as it's often the
most viable tactic and it plays into the
game's cyclical murderous bliss
the tension of facing increasingly
durable enemies gives this system
longevity despite its repetitiveness to
keep up with the ever-growing board of
demons you must use resources earned for
your past feats to modify and upgrade
your weapons with new capabilities this
steadily feeds into your brash and
violent persona in order to maintain the
high of combat in the face of ever
growing tolerance for all things brutal
where a shotgun blast to the face was
once satisfying and effective enough you
ultimately desire the thrill and power
of an leashing a mortar like cluster
bomb from your double-barreled best
friend when he spent you'll be thankful
you upgraded your heavy assault rifle
with micro missiles that pierce the air
with a subtle whistle before lodging
under the skin of a demon and exploding
one after another secrets and hidden
areas aren't new to doom but the variety
of rewards you can reap are greater than
ever every bit of hardware including
weapons armor and their underlying
software can be augmented in multiple
ways the process of awkwardly
platforming your way across dooms Maps
in search of items does grow
increasingly tiresome as your pulse
drops to a murmur and your patience for
anything other than combat eventually
wears thin with a flush arsenal enhanced
physical abilities at the end of the
game you may opt to return to previous
missions to find items you may have
missed or to lay waste at higher
difficulty levels a multiplayer awaits
those who seek something new
unfortunately there's actually very
little knew about dooms multiplayer its
modes are few delivering the expected
assortment of match types including team
deathmatch and domination challenges and
it can be fun to step into the shoes of
a demon during a match but by and large
you won't find much in multiplayer that
hasn't been done before but what's there
is enjoyable in small doses thanks to
the fast pace of combat in the explosive
nature of dooms webinar more impressive
than multiplayer is snap map a mode that
allows you to create and share both
multi and single-player Maps online
tutorials walk you through the steps
involved in creating a map which is
already intuitive to begin with
snap map will live and die through the
creativeness of the community which has
already made a strong showing delivering
a collection of maps that range from
brutal to absurdly entertaining more
than multiplayer snap map is the cherry
on top of the new do
but without a doubt a loud and chaotic
campaign is due strongest component it's
straightforward and simple but it serves
its purpose to thrust you into
increasingly dire scenarios fueled by
rage and the spirit of heavy metal it
captures the essence of what made the
classic dune games touchstones of their
day and translates it to suit modern
palates with impressively rendered hell
escapes and a steady influx of
tantalizing upgrades doom is the product
of a tradition as oldest shooters and
while it's not the model to follow in
every case modern shooters could learn a
thing or two from dooms honed and
unadulterated